[Music]
inside hustle use Joe has a lot of them
yeah
submit it by ling-ling ling-ling
ling-ling it's like a king with a
gesture that deserts like a ling playing
you will come back you know you know
puns yeah you know some people really
like puns and it's not that funny but it
makes them happy yeah and I [ __ ] want
to punch those people say these things
you wanna punch no no don't make me hit
a woman I love you're a Mike have you
guys seen that episode when [ __ ] wolf
arrow was the boss yeah and then Andy he
kept hurting himself but that's the only
thing that will Pharaoh would laugh at
yeah so he just had to keep my burning
himself with my Poppy's [ __ ] that's what
it reminds me of a woman running for
City Council is defending her online
alter-ego who sells use of candies how
did she get caught that's separate from
ability to be a good politician yeah I'd
like that because like you know what
we're just hold people hurt used pennies
we could be professional and sometimes
we want to have sex in a public restroom
we should sell your used panties you
know that's how much would you guys pay
for somebody start the bids or now they
are not for sale
one grand you can't buy off me get there
can buy right tip how much for yours
Kenny we've had this conversation so
many times I'm so dirty I've gotten
proposal for feet stuff for like Oh for
like socks and stuff oh yeah that - can
I get photos of your feet there was this
one girl that was like hey um you know I
wanted
I wanna get my boobs done I think your
boobs are really nice would you mind
sending me a photo of your boobs I just
wouldn't know anything true I just want
to see like you know between girls yeah
you think girls do stranger girls that
have never met coach you like trust me
I'll never send it to anyone like I
literally want to meet this dude and
slap the [ __ ] out of them he's a genius
it's people so disrespectful like how he
thinks you're that stupid please yeah
that's the disrespect but even like the
asking for tits part yeah it's the whole
like how many hits like a regular dude
you might actually get up you should
have said I'm a dick pic prove it Oh
next to each other so it looks like
boobs just the balls like that looks
like a neck and then the balls that's
good yeah you'll get in trouble right
if that happens a very young person you
know what you should do you thought of
everything
you like little things right so so a
little bra and then get a C's ball sack
right and then make put the broad as
Casey
Casey's ball sack and then record it and
then let it snap off oh you know what
you could what about if you did it with
an orangutan ball sack because they're
not human so it's not sexual
reproduction yeah just fine in a ring at
a night off the street and so
complicated sooner eggs no come on
sophistry alright anyway let's not be
ridiculous today all right you don't
even think about googling we're trying
to really solve a problem here and
you're going to joke where are you gonna
get this alright it's a serious if I
consider this this woman her name is
Debra
she's from Wyoming and she's running for
her little like city politics way to
patronize her
because she was saying like I didn't
think people would really get this
serious just like just small-town
politics that's well that's why I know
it's like I just think it's so cool that
you're doing exactly what Tony Atef
she's like nah mosquito you burn people
you [ __ ] when you burn people you
moral combat fatality then dude you rip
their [ __ ] spine out Richard thanks
for uplifting the patriarchy all right
oh god yes a very small population
though so I got your back it's very
small bad for this padding sniffing lady
dude yeah dude newer she's a skid mark
monetizing paintings yeah any higher oil
supplies yo check this out
panty pimp yeah don't like I sell this
overseas so I'm creating jobs for
Americans there's a market in Japan that
buys all this [ __ ] reminds me of orange
is the new black when they sold prison
panties yeah oh that's right prison
panties yeah yeah because they said they
sold them for more there was like a
demand for like a prisoner girl's
panties more than perfect but then her
brother who was like the the mule for
getting these like panties out they
found out that they can make a similar
scent at home like manufacture it and so
then they were manufacturing their own
prison pants I just I just don't even
want panties to exist
well pennies are necessary
mm all right so Deborah here this is
what she looks like
you didn't even wear it
ah she she looks this woman literally
looks like a tree came to life that's a
good one yeah she looks like Steven
Tyler she looks like this she does it's
not a good photo of this woman obviously
it's just an unfortunate voter so she
has an alter ego online where she spells
use candy the jury
dude would it be a willow tree or a pine
tree
something very barky that's all women
helping women bro we have a female in
power and you want to bring her down
this is why Hillary was not president
men learn from men right absolutely
we're stupid remember I don't know why
you should yeah this shirt looks more
like a bark tree reflection
self-deprecation women have each other's
backs in this world okay yep anyway so
she has an alter ego named misty
Crockett it's like Davy Crockett tomato
yeah
okay here's Debra's like running
campaigns we know that's your last name
oh okay working hard for everyone wait
so demander isn't her last name this is
like before batter her name whoa like
she's like the demander deborah demand
arena must be in quotes yes not a good
slogan it should have been something
like smells like success or something
you know something like that you gotta
play with it yeah so then here's like
her website where she'll like striptease
she has striptease videos we're under
like misty Crockett good body Wow good
job and there is like she's like I'm
misty USA girl next door' sharing
fantasies and fetishes with youth panty
buyers and my friends yeah you're
definitely a girl anymore but alright
let's go from there Wow
Davey's a milf next door milf yeah but
she's a tree she's not a girl no this is
not going back to David you guys keep
the ball in your hand he's allowed to
put it in there okay hot potato stays
with you
what I'm saying is that if you say girl
next door I'm thinking no she said girl
next door all grown up in naughty
no that's the bill that's what she wrote
I'm not it's been a treat we don't want
you back corner lock the door behind
thank you no oh yeah she's like I said
most of my life being a good girl good
little girl doing as I was told
and never misbehaving now that I'm all
grown up I love to live life on the wild
side I have a dirty naughty streak and
I'd love to help you discover can you
slow down a little bit while you're
reading this yeah I'm kind of getting
into kana I want to call my answer I
wanted a little more preppy and airy -
please be our concern there it is and
keep up the professional very thank Jess
later boys
night jackoff ASMR style that goes
better in my neck night and on the
weekends I play dirty picture the
Trina's boners now treat a lady boner
it's like a minute sitcom audience and
two people just kiss him like alright so
yeah so that's her right and so there
was all this like controversy around her
still running for City Council
but then she ended up saying like no you
know what I'm not gonna drop out I'm
gonna continue running yeah you have a
choice to vote for her too so it's not a
scandal she did delete all of her
profiles and everything like she says
that's uh you should bring that back
because she's probably not gonna win
this City Council thing but then she
could get a lot more you want a
politicians panties yeah check that out
pre politicians pre politicians you want
a girl she would daddies for like 20
bucks I'm like girl her gym shorts would
be for 20 bucks plus shipping we do that
cheaper than the actual chair really
expensive well it's a baby she buys in
my Costco Wholesale and you don't want
Amazon or she does like the Victoria's
Secret 525 thing that's so expensive
I wonder if guys as like can you sweat
in these like at the gym and I'm pretty
sure dude hi sweater gotta get enough
fluids in there to make it worth it
somebody offered you a lot of money for
your undergarments or your socks or your
shirt or whatever you think the most
someone asked for my dirty panties is
like 500 bucks that's good and you
didn't give them out yeah it's probably
same person ya know cuz I don't like
even though I say it like come on to
actually go through it
[ __ ] if that venmo thing goes ding like
send your share some underwears that I
think you should get rid of so you
should sell it holy
I do have some older maybe I would sell
someone else's underwear isn't stay
there it's been it's it's got a lot of
miles on them don't like it and give
that other person a cut and you're
pimping yeah panty like I don't want my
DNA out there but I mean the government
has my DNA what is some [ __ ] [ __ ]
really gonna do make a joke of murder
some bad [ __ ] why do you think money's
at $500 no no I'm saying no is good
amount me for a pair of cloth like this
big yeah but like but I don't know I
just [ __ ] sneeze on it who can't get
exactly dude he's rubbed rub it on the
cat's room I'll rub it on my ass no no
just think I smell like oh I see there's
like a peony somalis out there like mmm
California she's vegan
no but vegan for eight months so at one
point oh yeah wait she ate something
with there was a little bit of chicken
in it and then she said oh no this
chicken is a yeast problem in her
stomach
Costard Candida
[Music]